pour bien comprendre le commerce des
esclaves
il suffit de connaître l'histoire du
sucre 74% des esclaves déportés l'ont
été à cause du sucre
sur les plages des caraïbes
les captifs débarque en tant que noir
dans un monde dominé par les blancs l'
esclavage produit de la richesse qui est
une richesse essentielle pour pour la
france plus la demande en sucre est
forte plus la traite se développe plus
les négriers cherche l'appui des banques
pour financer leur expédition
[Musique]
le prix d'un esclave est amorti en
quatre ans après sa vie n'a de valeur
que s'il peut encore tenir une machette
c'était ça la plantation
c'était cette odeur s'écrier cette
erreur qui obligeait les esclaves à
travailler et à obéir à leurs maîtres
il est impossible de dissocier cette
terreur dû au travail sur la plantation
des profits qui en résulte